many people going bonkers about the
reportedly accepted offer for elon musk
to buy twitter
there are people who on the right are
welcoming this with open arms saying
free speech will return to twitter and
oh it's going to be great and you have
people on the left saying this is a
dystopian nightmare let's talk through
what's going on and then i will give you
my take on it twitter has accepted elon
musk's buyout deal the report is that
twitter's board has accepted the uh
offer for elon musk to take the company
private twitter's a publicly traded
company right now the idea would be that
elon musk has secured financing at 54.20
per share to buy the company and to take
it private
there were rumors floating that many
said there's no way this is happening
and it appears to be now it still needs
to actually go through the due diligence
and regulation phase and it's possible
that this will fall apart but i'm more
concerned with what the reaction to this
should be
now one of the problems i'm having with
the reaction for many
is that it is very very black and white
either this is our elon musk is our
savior and he's going to save twitter
and he's going to unban everybody and
trump will be back and all these
different things and then the other side
of it is that this is the absolute worst
thing that could happen because elon
musk is just an absolutely terrible
person one of the problems that we're
facing in the united states
and around the world but in the united
states is that everything is based
around personalities and and cults of
personality and i think we should resist
that and we should resist it very
strongly as i've said before when it
comes to elected officials
i don't see politicians and elected
officials as being any different than
you or i they're just people they have
some good ideas they have some bad ideas
they have good instincts they have bad
instincts and we've talked about the
dangerous cult of personality around
donald trump but i was the first to tell
you as a bernie supporter in 16 and 20.
i didn't like the cult of personality
that developed around bernie bernie can
do no wrong oh you don't like what he
said well you must have misunderstood
what he said or you're deliberately
misstating what he said he no he can do
no wrong cult of personality around
tulsi gabbard there was one around
andrew yang there's one around jordan
peterson i'm against all of it we need
to just see people
as uh more nuanced than that and so when
we talk about someone like
elon musk who's that's who's that
question here
does elon musk have a history of um
suppressing unionization at his
companies yeah yeah and i'm against that
that's not good
has elon musk
dramatically accelerated the path
forward on a number of important
technologies 100 percent
the current
rush that every manufacturer of
automobiles has not only to put out
electric vehicles but to put out
electric vehicles whose range can match
that of tesla
is only happening because of what elon
musk did with tesla and
at tesla bad things have also happened
there's allegations of racism there's
allegations of union busting all of
these different things but the tesla
advancement of electric vehicles with a
greater than 300 mile range as a just
normal thing has led to
chevy
ford audi mercedes rivien all these
different companies saying hey we gotta
up our game we've got to compete here
that's a great thing
when you talk about the return to space
and spacex
musk reinvigorated what is now an
increased interest in getting back to
space which i think is good
starlink satellite internet anywhere in
the world these are great things and
from a business standpoint
i've learned it's not a good bet to bet
against elon musk when he's determined
to do something and he also has some
terrible political instincts tweets
horrible things
and has all of these other things that
that aren't very progressive to me
uh the track record on free speech as we
we have a report from cnbc about uh
musk's record on free speech it's not a
great record he has sought control over
what journalist bloggers analysts and
others say about his businesses he's
reportedly cancelled people's
a blogger's tesla order when the blogger
blogged something elon musk didn't like
so what does this mean for twitter i
have absolutely no idea it could be bad
there's no doubt about it but i think
the problem i'm having is that all of
the discussion 99 of the discussion is
based around people's pre-existing
opinion about elon musk as a uniquely
great figure or as a uniquely terrible
figure and that seems extraordinarily
short-sighted my main concern with musk
buying twitter
is that of consolidation and monopoly
i don't really love the idea
of one person controlling so many major
companies elon musk's going to control
twitter
and tesla which is now i believe by
market cap the largest auto manufacturer
in the united states
uh and spacex which is i believe the
most important private space exploration
come it start the consolidation of power
is my uh primary concern will trump be
back on twitter as a result like is elon
musk planning to unban trump i have
absolutely no idea trump says he doesn't
plan to go back on that may change that
seems like a minor detail at this point
so let me know your thoughts about the
twitter takeover but try to make them
substantive rather than driven by just
your opinion of elon musk as an
individual which the right just is
they're praying at the altar of musk
and it seems unhinged
and also i'm seeing some on the left who
are just
painting him as a uniquely evil
character which also doesn't strike me
as accurate let me know your thoughts
i'm on twitter at deepakman
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy dot com slash pacman the
link is right underneath this video